Irma from the survival era revives
now
[music]
I'm going to eat fake star ingredients The
point is, the
point is to make it solid
Burma is suddenly a survival cup Pushed by that excessive
spirit
Lead 1
Music]
We spent a time without even the slightest bit of tension up to the
present
Leader, your meal is ready
Hurry up Hurry up Hurry up Hurry up
Hurry up You can't eat the whole
thing It's a harvest festival, right?
I
came here to see
Ishii rice is ready Ishii rice is
ready.  Let's go
, that
's right
All the points have been eaten up, so we're going to win now Has there ever been a
battle like this?
You're the great enemy of survival On the
first day, you don't have points to accumulate stamina and knowledge, so you
won't be targeted It
makes sense, I think
Iruma-kun Written by Iruma-kun
preservation preservation